en tout cas je félicite guillaume je me
réjouis de son entrée à l'assemblée
nationale je le connais bien puisqu'il
est conseiller régional de bourgogne et
je pense que ce sera un excellent député
puis je pense aussi à jean pierre
soisson quand on est en période de
succession je pense que c'est une joie
de voir que la maison reste entre les
mains des mêmes personnes
on était ensemble semaine
vous vous continuer à espérer une
majorité pour la droite et une
éventuelle cohabitation d'évidence sais
pas ce qui va se passer
je n'ai jamais parlé de victoire de la
droite parce que je crois à l'effet très
fort de des résultats des
présidentielles ce serait une bien
grande incohérence de la part des
électeurs s'il y avait un tel revirement
par contre je pense je pense
effectivement que nous pouvions avoir un
groupe suffisamment fort pour que le ps
n'est pas la majorité absolue oui ça se
faisait partie des objectifs qui me
semble est avec génial on sait jamais un
mot qu'on aime utiliser en politique
c'est une déception je vous le laisse
mais c'est une déception indéniablement
on ne peut pas dire autrement